hey I'm James Gunn the writer and
director of guardians of galaxy vol 3
and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
and I'm Sean Gunn I play cragland and
I'm James sidekick in real life that's
right
is James Gunn related to Sean Gunn he is
his brother we are brothers
we are one of two of six children I hope
none of them are harder than that is
James Gunn directing Superman Legacy
James Gunn is directing Superman Legacy
like Legacy we start shooting in uh
January yeah you could have answered
that no you answer the next I'll give
you the next one is James Gunn the Kevin
feige of DC
foreign
of course you made me take the hard one
uh there's a Venn diagram where the what
they do is similar and there's part of
it what they do it's actually well it's
actually a little different I mean
remember what DC Studios is a studio so
it's a little bit different Peter
saffron does a lot of what Kevin feige
does a lot of what I do is I just work
on the creative side of things so
mapping out the stories and the creative
side of the universe is my job much more
so than some of the more administrative
executive type stuff Kevin has to do
both I thought it was a baseball cap
question I thought it was about how
often you wear baseball caps I wear
baseball caps never is James Gunn an
autor oh my God I don't know it's a
weird question I mean because like what
I don't know what that means exactly
there's so much baggage to it I mean not
a tour Theory means that the director is
the author of the film and I am
definitely the biggest voice in a film I
make all the choices I draw all the
frames but no matter what there are a
lot of people that work on a movie a
production designer a costume designer a
DP they all affect the movie not to
mention her some actors you know is
James Gunn married I can answer that one
the answer to that is yes she's right
over there
and I married them he did you officiated
at the wedding I officiated the wedding
and I officiated his wedding so that's
true all right do I get this one who is
Sean Gunn and Guardians of the Galaxy
first of all he plays a role of craglin
who is the first mate of the ravager
ship and goes on to become a guardian of
the galaxy in volume three and in Thor I
guess but he also plays Rocket on set
which means he Waddles around on all
fours he does all the motion capture for
rocket on all twos and a lot of the
times when you see Rockets uh
Expressions that's actually Sean's
acting and then Bradley Cooper comes in
and does the voice and in this movie you
actually also play Young rocket which he
does the voice for young rocket when
Rocket's a toddler he's correct thank
you
is correct I passed did I get 100 who is
Sean Gunn look alike who do people say
you look like I used to get Sam Smith
all the time yeah I remember like a
younger sexier shotgun Sean Gunn motion
capture well I think we kind of talked
about this is that I've done motion
reference for for six movies of Rocket
which is a little different it's just a
a reference point for the visual effects
team but I also did some motion capture
work as Rocket in this third movie when
rocket is Young
um and I've also done motion capture as
weasel and The Suicide Squad it's
something that has become a part of my
career that I never expected can Sean
Gunn Direct that's on Google I don't
know what does Google say about that I
used to direct theater many years ago
yeah there's a part of me that thinks
that maybe someday I'll do something
behind the camera but I love being an
actor so so much I'm not one of these
actors just like I want to do something
else you know I love it so much that the
idea is sometimes it's enticing
sometimes not you don't want to do it
yeah okay what was James Gunn first
movie first movie I ever did was a movie
called tromeo and Juliet but and really
direct it directed aspects of it but
that was my first movie The First movie
I directed was a horror movie called
Slither with Nathan Fillion and Michael
Rooker and Greg Henry and Elizabeth
Banks and I've put them all in numerous
movies since that time yeah if you
haven't seen it you should see it it's
really good what movies did James go on
right all of the movies that you
directed all the movies that you
directed so Slither super three
Guardians movies Suicide Squad both
Scooby-Doo movies yeah the first one and
then Monsters Unleashed so if
classic I remember oh and Romeo
obviously Dawn of the Dead um yeah right
you wrote down to the dead Belco
experiment velco experiment I think
there's a couple more it's a lot of
movies yeah made a lot of movies what is
James gun directed I think we just kind
of went over that I directed an end two
minute and credit sequence over movie 43
and so I often get credited with movie
43. your finest work it brings down my
Rotten Tomatoes score quite a bit
what is James Gunn working on now I'm
working on uh Superman Legacy which we
shoot in January
um I'm doing the Press tour for
Guardians of Galaxy Vol 3. we've been
recording voices for our animated show
Creature Commandos and then I'm helping
other writers work on other projects in
the DC world
but movies has Sean Gunn watched this
could be a long list what movies has
Sean Gunn been in okay you were in Pearl
Harbor that's a pretty long one you're
in trouble and Juliet yeah you were in
what's the movie with Jamie Kennedy
where you played a dead body for a
second half of the movie stricken Thor
love and thunder you were in Guardians
movies of course you know you were in
The Avengers movies yeah what else were
you in let's see Belco experiments yep
some of the Indie movies I've done my
gosh the tour Theory boy called Poe who
the f is Buddy Apple bomb were you in
the hive The Hive I don't know how many
it is overall but I would guess it's
around 20. when Sean Gunn was discovered
you were discovered in numerous I
remember you were on the Andy Richter
show when we first came to La your claim
to fame initially was Kirk on the
Gilmore Girls which you were on for
seven years yes and uh bought you a
house when Sean Gunn a appeared on
Gilmore Girls when did you appear on
Gilmore Girls I was on the second
episode of the first season so it was
like I came in kind of right out of the
gate and I played a character named the
DSL installer which dates myself and the
show
and uh they kind of just kept asking me
back to play other small roles and it
just went on and on what season did you
become a regular on the show season
three when did you get a name I actually
got a name pretty quickly I got a name
in like the third or fourth episode
oh my God every single day four decades
you gotta real realize how popular
Gilmore Girls is on is on Netflix now
and it's just PL it's like one of the
most popular shows of all time does Sean
Gunn play rocket I participate in the
creation of Rocket it kind of takes a
team of people there's the writer and
there's me and there's a visual effects
team and there's Bradley Cooper and
between all of us together we create
yeah I think it's one of the reasons why
I'm so attached to the characters
because he almost seems real because
it's all these people kind of coming
together to create this character that's
bigger than all of them does
James Gunn
wow what uh search Google for
this
somebody looking for some dirt
oh wait a second you're you're the one
that that googled this
question
foreign
I started making movies together when
when I was 11 and he was like you know
five or whatever we've never gotten into
a fight about like a creative thing no
no no never ever so it's just really
fluid I'm ended up like oh yeah we well
we worked together on set but like they
really those guys really don't it would
be weird if it was the other way around
considering how many times I've chosen
to work with yeah I know I know you know
it would be like what yeah does James
Gunn read Comics I read tons of comic
books I always have oh absolutely does
James Gunn dye his hair James Gunn does
not dye his hair this is James Gunn's
actual hair color
neither strong gun by the way did James
Gunn go to college he did I did go to
college I went to Loyola Marymount got
kicked out of that school then I went to
St Louis University and then I went to
uh graduate school at Columbia
University did James Gunn direct
Peacemaker yes I directed five of the
Eight Episodes of Peacemaker did James
Gunn help with infinity I did I helped
with infinity War I was an executive
producer and I just helped to guide the
Guardians along that process
Sean Gunn weasel yes agree
Sean Gunn rocket voice in this new movie
I do I do a little section of of
adolescent rocket but I bet they're
wondering like what you sound like on
set when you do rocket I try not to like
do that yeah yeah yeah yeah but there is
a voice yeah there is yeah Sean Gunn
Creature Commandos John Gunn plays
weaseline Creature Commandos but he also
plays GI robot yeah an actual person who
can speak words well he's not a person
he's a robot yeah he's a robot but uh
hates nuts it's good oh Nazis are the
worst huh yeah yeah and he agreed and
it's good to not just be weasel and be
like yeah yeah he has like come in for
two hours of squealing Sean Gunn looks
like Sam Smith I told you I told you
Sean Gunn LinkedIn you have a LinkedIn
nope like eons ago like when it first
came out never I still don't know how to
log in you know LinkedIn used to be the
worst about you'd sign up for LinkedIn
and it would send out LinkedIn
invitations to everybody in uh your
phone book and I remember getting a
LinkedIn invitation I think from Rob
Zombie one time which I thought was the
funniest thing in the world
he's looking for a step up in the world
he's gonna make some business
connections on LinkedIn okay James James
has one more what a surprise James James
Gunn favorite movies I have a lot of
favorite movies
um among them are the long goodbye uh
Robert Altman film with Elliott Gould I
love uh Bob and Carol and Alice Paul
mazurski film I love After Hours by
Martin Scorsese I Live Once Upon a Time
in the West by Sergio Leone I I love a
lot of movies
um James Gunn Funko Pops I do have a
Funko Pop it's uh worth about uh five
six seven hundred dollars online if you
it on eBay I have one I'm really excited
if you want to buy one
unloaded James Gunn influences James gun
influences I have I mean listen I'm
influenced by every movie I see but I
will give a shout out to a lot of Asian
Cinema which has been a big part of what
I feel like I've done I fell in love
with Hong Kong movies when I was a very
young man and I watched you know
hundreds of them owned them on video
cassette uh sometimes not exactly legal
sorry because you couldn't watch Hong
Kong movies in the United States they
weren't well distributed so I was very
influenced by the way that uh Hong Kong
movies in particular at that time mixed
drama comedy you know edgy stuff and
then of course the way they shot action
was like nothing before it and I feel
the same way about many Japanese movies
many Korean films my dog is named ozu
after the great director Japanese
director so James Gunn king shark James
gun king shark yeah King shark's a
character that I having the suicide
squad that I wrote and played by
Sylvester Stallone who is also in
Guardians of the Galaxy James Gunn
lollipop jeans Lollipop Chainsaw is a
game that I wrote with the Fantastic
suda from Japan and it was a
Japanese-American co-production and it
was a blast we had a lot of Guardians
people in that because Linda Cardinals
in the game who plays Lila the otter
you're in the game you played like the
bad guy
Swan Tara Strong plays Julius Starling
who's like the main character and she
plays Mainframe now in the Guardians
franchise Michael Rosenbaum who plays
Martin X plays her boyfriend who's a
beheaded guy who she wears around her
waist it's a weird game Rooker Rooker
plays a pirate or something or a viking
or something like that yeah what do you
think of your Google search engine
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]